avec mon ami nous menons des expériences
depuis quelques années de pop végétales
mais aujourd'hui l'instant est grave
nous pensons avoir mis au point une
méthode permettant de dialoguer avec les
plantes
[Musique]
et dès 2021 début de l'expérience des x
7 points 2 tentatives numéro 15 avec le
professeur la graine nous pensons avoir
mis au point une méthode permettant le
dialogue avec l'ensemble du règne
végétal note interne
tel est le cas la nouvelle devrait faire
l'effet d'une bombe pour l'ensemble de
la communauté scientifique mais pour le
moment nous restons prudents après ce
devra être au courant les tentatives
numéro d 11 à 14 ans ont montré lors de
stimulation sonore bien mais ça dit
heather polyphonique l'émission
d'organites de contacts dans la sève
élaboré transitant par le flot m
plus clairement l'analyse des collines
va permis de déceler le message suivant
[Musique]
on ce drame qui est une délicieuse la
mettons viens tu
[Musique]
montez l'âme qui est
délicieuse as tu veux tu seulement
quelques mois plus tard dans notre
laboratoire avec les dents nous convions
communiqué après avoir installé le
système de traduction vocale développé
par la graine pour traduire le signal
végétale du spécimen l'étude qui fit
notera fortune
dans les faits lui ne compte plus les
heures à dialoguer avec ses fleurs et
tout s'est passé
nous avons tenté
électrique quand très vite ses racines
les applis si nous étions stupéfaits le
végétal dans
il s'est glissé tout ces tiges
sont échappés dès lors tout sur les
building
fleurs
économie
amour pour cette nature
de sa canopée
monthey l'âme qui est une délicieuse à
tout vient
montez ram qui es tu
deliciosa tu me tues
qui es tu
et on vient du monde dames qui est une
[Musique]
hélice là tu me tues
et
[Musique]
suivant